hi
welcome to we went back
a horror game set in space
about going back somewhere
because of course we did
or we will
anyway zooming interact object
inspection
you got it proceed to snap a photo when
it
zoom right mouse buttons okay got it
zoom zoom
zoom
zoom
i can't see that
right there
cryo sleep interrupted
life
detected what was that about a life form
that better be me
and i better actually be alive
anyway
um
hello
hello
hello hi how are you
i'm good good to see you
what was that about a life form
warning door has been deactivated
okay why is it bendy activated also exit
are we in space or are we not in space
what am i looking at
zoom
that's a lot of zoom
hi
okay
hi computer good morning
uh
password
uh
dick but
[Music]
all right
well that ain't working here
[Music]
okay
uh
oh surface okay so we must be actually
on the moon which makes sense looking at
all that out there
hello
hi hello
what's that
what are you
a camera
go back go back
go back
okay um
why what just happened
who what why why would you who did
pick
[Music]
what did i just see
hello
hello
[Music]
hello
who's there none of you actually better
have anybody in you
you better not you better be emptier i'm
going to punch my fist through you and
your bell you don't be empty you can be
empty off all your blood
when i punch it out my threats were
really substandard hello
hi
well
all right
h type okay can i get some coffee
i love some coffee
time and space
whatever same thing am i right
july 69 oh sure it is
sure it is the orbicular
oh is that where we are
that must be where we are
okay thank you
ah blends good great
i thought that was a cat i'm dumb
am i supposed to be picking things up
am i supposed to be looking close
mouse
hi rat
how are you you okay
good uh this is a weird diagram of a rat
well
fade the rat
pay fake
fee fi
fo and thumb i'm guessing that's the
name of your siblings okay
butterflies
interesting
i imagine that somewhere here is the
actual
code that i need to put in to the
computer terminal so i can unlock it
unless this is going to be a loop
it's going to loop isn't it
i
i knew it
well better get back in the pod i
suppose
hello
okay
i know what you're about
i know what's going on here
i know
i know what's going on
oh my god
don't
i will kill you i will kill you and i
will destroy you and i will annihilate
you
you're cool and all of you are dead what
is this
operational good minimal minimal uh oh
why is that a red operational
you all shut up
i will kill you you fall down
fell down i can't get over you
apparently i'm terrified of that
[Music]
i can't possibly do anything about this
i couldn't pop
hey you guys see that did you guys see
that do you just gonna do anything about
that are you gonna watch
all right and i go head first
that's what i always say
hello hi bruno
wow oh oh
ah i see
okay so it's phases right
so if there's five here again a e i o
and u
can i can't seem to do anything
i i need to take photos okay so i'm
looking for these symbols okay so i'm
looking for like phases of the moon i
think that's definitely what that's
about
so i need to find faces of the moon and
then take pictures of them so that i can
see what they are
uh okay
huh
okay
definitely some puzzly puzzles here
nothing important for me
nothing i need to worry about
hey how you guys doing
hey good to see you all right you stay
sexy
you stay beautiful everybody over there
okay so somewhere here there's gotta be
items that have symbols on them right
it's mushroom what is that sound
okay that yeah that's a camera
med kit someone already got i i thought
i saw a picture of that med kit there
already
or something similar help huh i don't
know about that
it's probably more obvious because
oh cool
alternating universe apollo 11.
so there's gotta be things that actually
you could interact with by pressing the
use key on them that's probably got
these plants always tiny
bee
bay
fife
okay i'm not seeing anything to work
with why are those out here
hey you be good fee
faye
okay
what got quiet
why did he get quiet
why did it get quiet
why why is he why is he quiet
get loud damn it
okay it's probably fine
all right
well this isn't what i was expecting
but that's okay
i love new things hey that's new
ah
wham i'm taking a photo
scuba am
[Applause]
okay
good
oh hi
it's me again
oh wow it's me again
oh oh wow it's me again
yeah i i i got it
i i might have missed it last time and
maybe this is my punishment for not
getting it i get it
i get what i missed
i got it
uh
oh my god
okay good good good the orbicular
can i uh
why is it droopy
who's in my pod
you better be naked or dead in there
[Music]
that's weird
huh
anyway
moving on
i think i can go put this
i think i can go put this polaroid in
the um
in the thing now as long as there's not
something in the vent waiting for me
hello hi it's me hi hello
how are you okay so you
[Music]
if this is that
that doesn't quite make a lot of sense
but
so theoretically
is there some uh
some way to know the letters could be c
i don't know what you are
i'll just go get more pictures then
it'll all make sense definitely 100 it's
all gonna make sense
oh boy this room again glad to be here
thank you
oh oh we got a flashing light here
what do we got in here
anything in here
seems awfully suspicious that there'd be
a flashing light right here i can't seem
to open it though so
i don't think that's gonna do me any
good
okay
fee
[Music]
fee
[Music]
fee
fee
fee
five fo
fifo farm
full
okay it's fine
it's fine
hi
well this is uh i guess i missed my
stuff right hi
this
is a hand it's a hand it's a hand it's
not a glove it's a hand
saw i should have noticed that that
seems like that should have been
noticeable
yeah it wasn't
i don't know how i missed it
well i guess i just get to go back now
at least it's nice enough to show me
where i was stupid as opposed to just
like letting me be stupid longer now
gets to make fun of me for being stupid
not being able to actually solve the
problem that was right in front of my
face so thank you for that
game
okey-dokey
[Music]
who's in my pod
no one no one's in my pod
oh hey i didn't even notice that
weird
okay
um
oh good
is that from the uh oh my god
all right cool good
thank you for that really appreciate it
why why
why
i'm going i'm going i'm going
okay
it's awfully loud here
[Music]
what is with the purring it's a fade in
my brain
there's a thing there
it's been a record player
i don't know the ominous music is really
cranking
i i don't know
good
oh
what was that
i don't know what's happening i don't
know what's happening i'm just gonna
keep going
hey
yay
oh
[Music]
hi i'm coming for you baby
[Music]
am i dead
i'm not dead
i'm not faye faye
okay
all right
we're on the lookout for even more stuff
really hunting up a storm this time
we already got something from that room
we already got this from this room
uh
oh no
no
no
no
why would you do that
why would you do that
that's mean
why would you do that
that's really mean that's really mean
okay fine
i was about to say i am ready to stand
my ground here
i'm ready to throw down you think i'm
not but i am
i got the fighting spirit in me why is
it
was that always interact did i always
see it i did miss it in this room i knew
it the butterfly
the flutter but okay it wasn't the
flutterbye okay then what was it
um
oh fee is gone
this is not what i think it is
hello
what am i what am i looking for
the my ah
of course
the microscope
all right i got it i'm on my way i know
i'm very dumb
but there's only so many rooms left that
i could possibly get an item in so
therefore
get ready for my intelligence to burst
through
and we're back looks like we got some
kind of a coolant leak in here hey how
you doing
oh god looks like we got
a lot of problems
hey
okay i'm gonna go in my little hidey
hole now hope nothing's in here
hi
hello
okay so i have five of six
i'm not exactly closer to solving the
puzzle
um because i can't move those so those
must be indicative of
the actual solution somehow i don't know
how but somehow i need one more i'll
figure it out later
i will get the solution
i thought that i thought i thought
i thought
i thought for a brief mome
oh
great the orbicular's looking good
february 1600
oh
check your
blood oxygen levels
great
okay
good stuff
[Music]
fay
fee franken feed
wow
upgrades hey that's pretty good uh was
there did i i didn't get one here yet
but oh
wow
great
good
all right that was the first
[Applause]
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
so i i also just realized i realized
what i'm doing which is i'm trying to
figure out what the password is to put
into the computer terminal so that it
psychedelic
kind of cool
so uh
oh
boy
oh boy um
you uh you
okay it's fine
you will watch the spongebob in here
oh
[Music]
ah um
okay
[Music]
okay
ah
okay interesting
ah oh
i see
so this was i i is not that one
i is actually
this one yeah that's it oh
i did it
f-l-u-i-e-t
so
this is a
toffee
okay fine
this is uh ah it's it's futile
fun
okay i know when i'm not supposed to be
here anymore futile
oh god wait hold on
uh
hello
peekaboo peekaboo peekaboo alert
oh good okay can i go back hello oh god
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh
oh oh
no
[Music]
the oregano
okay all right
[Music]
all right um
see that you burning
okay well at least i know it's futile
oh
don't mind me just walking very slowly
smoke
[Music]
behind
hey don't touch me
why does this feel familiar
oh
life form detected
please proceed to the nearest exit
terminal
okay i will um
bam
all right
i did it
i'm freaking out of here
later nerds see around the bend
have fun being dead
where am i going by the way are are we
on the moon i don't think
[Music]
well that was we went back
i like that a lot i like that a lot
i mean you know me i always love space
stuff but that was really cool
very very fun
very very fun
thank you to everybody that made this
game thank you everybody for watching me
play this game and if you want to play
this game for yourself link is in the
description
go check it out it's really fun
deserve some love too seemed well made
too i mean it was short obviously but i
i kind of like condensed little things
oh you know i i don't mind them at all
very fun oh there we have it so thank
you again everybody for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye
[Music]